fric frac oui mais non pas un fric-frac
en chansons comme celui que vous avez vu
lundi et des missions des partis mr un
fric-frac en paroles en somme puisque
précisément derrière cette porte habite
georges descrières qui a présenté le
fric frac en chansons alors nous voulons
lui dire quelques mots
pas mal ici la personne
ah je vous attendais bonjour jours
asseyez-vous alors comme ça vous faites
un fric-frac chez moi et bien sommes
tout autant les téléspectateurs moi je
vous rend la politesse puisque vous vous
avez fait voter un fric-frac leur
précisément à ce propos comment se
fait-il que les sociétaires de la
comédie française
hirsch manuel charron et vous et bien
d'autres semblent avoir une sorte de
davie de faire ce qu'on appelle des
variétés et bien parce que ça nous plaît
énormément
nous aimons beaucoup les variétés et
ensuite parce que ça nous change du
répertoire classique que nous aimons
beaucoup moi j'aime beaucoup le théâtre
français
mais en sortant deux
jouer pau lieu tout andromaque ou des
pièces assez sérieusement tout temps
vincent par le fil à la patte houleux où
le dindon il m'est très agréable de
participer à des émissions de variétés
complètement farfelues comme celles que
vous avez vu lundi dernier je remarque
d'ailleurs que les comédiens du
boulevard comme on dit à spirale inverse
à faire du classique wii où c'est un
phénomène de compensation jeu wilson
vous avez joué pratiquement presque tous
les rôles du répertoire comme on dit
presque tous n'ont quand même pas mais
enfin beaucoup déjà lequel préférez-vous
mais c'est le dernier en date que j'ai
joué c'est don juan
pourquoi parce que d'abord c'est un rôle
merveilleux c'est le plus beaux rôles du
répertoire et ensuite parce que c'est un
rôle qui est maintenant dans mon emploi
j'aspire maintenant à des rôles ce qu'on
appelle les premiers grands rôles dans
le répertoire classique
est ce que c'est une question si vous
voulez de maturité d'un jean quelque
sorte ou aussi une question morale
je crois que c'est les deux georges
descrières vous êtes comédiens à la fois
au théâtre au cinéma la télévision à la
radio même pouvez vous être un
spectateur et même un téléspectateur
comme les autres absolument
à genève je ne sais pas si les autres
comédiens sont comme moi mais
quand j'ai vu au théâtre je suis un
spectateur et je réagis comme un
spectateur je ne suis pas juge et partie
je reçois et quand la pièce est gay je
ris quand la pièce est triste et
dramatique
je ne pleure pas mais enfin je réagis en
fonction vous êtes bon public très je
crois vous êtes marié à une comédienne
très connu jeune fille brune et que nous
ne verrons malheureusement pas parce que
précisément elle tourne en ce moment en
mayenne et pour la télévision
il vous est arrivé assez souvent de
jouer ensemble et il agréable ou au
contraire plus difficile d'avoir sa
femme pour partenaire oui il est bien il
y a deux choses c'est à la fois plus
agréable et c'est à la fois moins
agréable parce que moins agréable car on
est inquiet pour deux vous savez que
plus on joue plus on a le trac et je me
souviens d'un mot de marguerite moreno
lors d'une interview à la radio on lui
disait mais voilà vous jouer d'une façon
absolument détendue reste que vous avez
peur elle dit oui j'ai peur et j'ai de
plus en plus peur et je crois que c'est
une question de responsabilité on est
responsable de ce que l'on fait on
ne veut pas décevoir un public qui vous
a vu apprécié dans certains rôles et
c'est pour ça qu'on a peur
alors on pense à sa femme est elle aussi
est dans le coup exactement agression
c'est pour ça qu'on a peur pour deux
vous avez des enfants
oui vous avez deux filles voilà l'un et
l'autre vous jouez beaucoup on vous êtes
constamment occupés est ce que vous
pouvez quand même vous occupez
l'éducation de vos enfants
oui et d'ailleurs où je veux pas dire
que nous dirigeons notre carrière en
fonction de notre vie familiale mais
nous ne laissons pas de côté ce
ce problème et c'est bien qu'il m'est
arrivé
ma femme également maintes et maintes
fois après avoir répété toute la journée
jouant le soir alors que nous étions
fatigués et bien lieu de nous reposer
nous rentrons et nous voyons nos enfants
pour qu'ils nous aient vu dans la
journée pour en profiter vous aussi
aigaliers je crois que notre devoir à
nous c'est de vous laisser maintenant à
vos enfants
oui il est l'heure d'ailleurs du
déjeuner et j'entends une de mes filles
qui m'appellent merci beaucoup je en
vrai